Rasheed, welcome to the stage. How you
doing?
>> How you doing? Uh, Avery, how you doing,
man? I'm
>> pretty good. I'm pretty good. Welcome to
this to the panel.
>> I appreciate your your invitation.
>> Mhm.
So, how would you like to engage? Would
you like to prove that any of the
prophets were Muslim?
>> Well, yes, I would like to prove that
the prophets are Muslim. uh first by
establishing the language in which it
was uh revealed in revelations such as
the let's start with the Psalms, the
Torah, the Inil. Uh I'm sure that's one
of your favorite that's your favorite
for
>> that's that's one of my favorites for
sure.
>> Okay. And the language uh in the Hebrew
or the Aramaic I would say that's the
language of our prophet Issa. May Allah
have uh peace and blessings be upon him.
The in the language itself even the
Hebrew the term to submit is mushlam
similar to the cemetic language Arabic
Muslim and uh in the Bible I'm not
talking about the Greek the testament of
Paul wouldn't use that language the
language of pagans Greek um that Muslim
means to submit. Sorry. You said that
you wouldn't use the language of Paul
Greek.
>> Well, I wouldn't use the language of
Paul. Well, this is what Well, your
Bible is you you refer to the New
Testament. It mostly refers to the Greek
rather than using the Hebrew or the
Aramaic the language of
>> I have a question on that. Like uh the
the word the word in do you know where
that derives from?
>> The word in
>> Yeah, the word in do you are you
familiar with where that derives from?
Well, where does it derive from?
>> It derives from the Greek word
evangelion.
>> Oh, does it?
>> So Jesus spoke when he was speaking
>> many languages, but specifically
>> Yeah, but he was sent to Banel and they
spoke Hebrew and they were in Israel. So
I don't think that he would speak Greek
>> to a native who would speak the language
of Hebrew. Well, if you're talking about
historically the the Israelites were
occupied by the Romans who spoke Greek.
So
>> yeah, but if he's speaking to the native
people, Israel, he would speak their
language, not Greek.
>> Well, if they spoke Greek, what's wrong
with that?
>> Well, no, we're saying that if he's
going, he was sent to the children of
Israel, the children of Jacob, the
nations of Jacob.
>> What language did they speak?
>> What language did they speak? Well, they
spoke a Seemetic language. Uh, and I
wouldn't say that it was because
languages varies throughout time when
>> Yeah. But how how do you know what how
do you know what language they spoke
specifically in Jesus's time?
>> Because they had to preserve the word,
the covenant.
>> Very good. And in order to preserve the
word, do you know what the Jews did in
order to preserve the Torah and the Old
Testament? Well, I would say before uh
the destruction of the first temple. Uh
and I would say during the Huh?
>> You're talking about way after that and
and Jesus is like a little bit before.
>> Well, I mean you have to preserve the
word when it was initially given, right?
Then you have to preserve it through
time. So it so from from as it was
presented by God the first time, let's
say with
>> that's not what I'm referring to,
brother. I'm I'm not referring to this.
>> I'm specifically
>> What are you referring to? I'm sorry.
>> And so the Jews were occupied by the
Romans. You're aware of that, right?
>> Yeah. They were occupied by the pagans.
Yes.
>> What did they have to do? The Jews, what
did they have to do to preserve the
Torah? Are you familiar?
>> What did they have to know? Maybe you
can educate me on that.
>> Sure. So they had to translate the Torah
and the Tanakh, the Old Testament, into
Greek, which is what is called because
they were occupied by the Romans. And so
the occup so they didn't they just lost
their their native tongue. They didn't
lose it, but because of the occupation
of the Romans and them being forced to
speak Greek and learn Greek and that
being the that being the uh the language
of the area that they had to make sure
they preserved it in the Greek as well.
>> Yeah. But but they still had they still
had the Torat though that was in Hebrew
and they spoke the language. So true.
I'm sure maybe I'm sure I'm sure like in
I'm sure that while they were you know
out and about they had to speak the
Greek because that may have become the
more prevalent language but when they
were amongst themselves in prayer and
worship they went back to the source
which is their language.
>> So you see how the Jews had no problem
translating their scripture into Greek.
It's called the Septuagent. Do you do
you know what the Septuagent is? And
when was that and when was that when was
that translated? When
>> that was a few it was a few hundred
years before Jesus was born. I'm not
exactly sure on the exact date, but it
was a few
>> Okay, that would make sense because I'm
sure as you're occupied and things
become a little hot and maybe you would
have to Yes. Yes. Yeah.
>> And and but at but I'm sure that they
and this was uh and I'm sure that but
still they still had original scriptures
and maybe as a uh a safeguard maybe yes
they would have to do that.
>> But then in doing so especially
uh translating uh a language from one to
the next you're going to lose some
things. you're not going to have, you
know, especially with the Greek language
because their their language was
basically their language was pretty much
what rooted in paganism. So their words
were used
>> for a a lang a language isn't pagan
itself, brother. People are
>> no but as it relates to their worship
terms that they use to worship. If if
you want to say if you want to say
>> rooted in paganism
>> if you want to say that then you have to
say that the language of the Quran the
Arabic language is rooted in paganism
because the Arabs were pagans before
Muhammad's prophethood right?
>> No they weren't. No they weren't.
>> Yes they did. They were pagans.
>> No they fell into paganism later on. But
in the in the beginning No.
>> When when were the Arabs not pagans?
>> Huh?
>> When were they? When Abraham when when
Abraham when the Abraham took by the uh
command of God his wife Hagar and his
child they weren't pagan.
>> When did Abraham go to go to Arab Arabia
>> when he when when you don't you don't
know that?
>> I know the claim. I'm asking for the
proof now. Like what's what?
>> Well, I mean there's a lot of histo
there's a lot of his there's a lot of
history in historians saying that it is
>> there's no there's not one historian
that says Abraham went to Arabia,
brother.
>> Oh, Pan. Where's Pan?
>> You're talking about Arabia.
>> Where's Piran? Maybe it wasn't called
Arabia back then because Yeah. But
where's Pan? We're talking about the
geographical area.
>> So,
>> let's not get caught up in the terms.
>> Okay. So in talking about you believe
that you believe Abraham went to Mecca
specifically and built the Cabba, right?
>> Well, it wasn't called Mecca back then.
>> I know. But you believe he went to where
Mecca is now and built the Cabba.
There's no evidence for that.
>> Yeah, because it's there.
>> That doesn't mean Abraham did anything.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> So Pan is where? But but yeah, but Pan
is But do you agree that Pan Where's
Piran? Where's where's the land of
>> P? Piran along with sir and along with
Sinai would be in the Sinai Peninsula in
which the Jews
>> Piran is not in the Saiy Peninsula.
>> Yes, it is.
>> Which we're talking about today. Piran
it might have been divine. Piran today
is not in the Sinai.
>> Okay. So let's let's get to some roots
then because we can agree to disagree on
that. I don't that's that doesn't that's
not any substance. What evidence do you
have to prove? And remember, not claim
because I I'm aware of what the Quran
claims. I'm asking for the proof that
these prophets were Muslim. Any of them
were actual Muslim.
>> Okay. Let's say, well, would you say
that Jesus
submitted to the what you would say the
father or the creator of the heavens and
the earth?
>> He submitted to his father. That's what
he says. So would he say that in Greek
or in Aramaic? What what what word would
he leave? What what what word or what?
>> He said it in both.
>> Okay. And what word would he what's the
word in Aramaic that he would use?
>> Aba.
>> He said aba. Father.
>> No, not father. Submit.
>> Do you want to see the verse?
>> Submit.
>> No. Where he calls his god that he
submits to.
>> Yeah. But if he he says that he would
submit, right? You said that he submits.
submits to his father specifically. Yes.
>> And and if he would say that I submit to
my father, what word would he use?
>> He says aba, what you
>> what variation of well aba is father but
what word would he use to say that he
submits?
>> I don't know the word in Greek or
Aramaic.
>> Well, and well in his language Aramaic
because he was sent to the children of
Israel. What does what does that matter
if he's
>> he would use the word he would use the
word the variation from uh of Muslim
which is Islam and he would say Muslim
>> I disagree not what that means in
Aramaic
>> well you you would you like to see what
it means in Aramaic you can look it up
>> can you can you be a can you be a Muslim
and believe that you're the that Allah
is your father
>> in what sense
>> any sense
>> can I be a Muslim and say that Allah is
my father.
>> Mhm.
>> Well, I would say two things. I would
say that if we're using it in your
sense, speaking to a Christian,
>> any sense.
>> Well,
>> straight straight answer. Straight
answer.
>> I'm trying to mention a sense. I'm
trying to mention a sense. Look, cuz
this is this is um
>> Yes. I would say that God Allah
>> can you is the
>> please please ask you a straightforward
straightforward question you can give me
a straightforward answer can you be a
Muslim
>> and say that Allah is your father in any
sense
>> only in one sense
>> okay so the answer
>> one can be from any right
>> yep that's right so there is a sense
that you can say that Allah is your
father can you show me this in the Quran
>> where we say Allah is my father
>> well Now see now let me educate you.
>> This is why the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would not use
father because he was sent to correct
those who distorted it. So he didn't
want to continue the confusion.
>> Can you show me using the word father?
>> Can you show me that
>> that can I show you what what are you
asking now?
>> Can you show me in the Quran that there
is a correct way in which Allah is the
father?
>> There's a correct way that Allah is the
father.
>> Yep. Meaning in the sense that I'm
talking about that he's the creator of
the heavens or the earth.
>> Yeah. In a is is there a a
>> he's a provider. He's the one who
provides.
>> Yep.
>> There's many verses that say that he's a
provider. He's the notice what you're
doing. I didn't ask.
>> So you're looking for the literal you're
looking for the literal term father. Is
that what? No, he wouldn't. Well, the
prophet through his hikmma and through
God's hikmma, he wouldn't do that
because that word was be that word was
being used to see confusion.
>> Okay.
>> So, he wouldn't
>> I got you.
>> He he he did say not he he did say that
>> he Okay.
>> Was the was the word Allah being used
for as confusion?
>> Did the word Allah Well,
>> yeah. Was the word Allah
>> used him Jesus used it himself. So, no.
>> Okay. So, the word
He he used it himself. So
>> he never used the word Allah. That's not
the same thing.
>> Eloy. Eloy.
Eloy is not Allah.
>> Okay. Do Yes. And do do you know the
Arabic terms? Do you know the vowels and
how to place the vowels and how to get
certain? There's a root word. There's a
method. There's Do you know? Are you
familiar with that in the Aramaic
language? I hear you loud and clear.
>> Okay. So, I'm gonna go I'm gonna show
you a Quran. I'm just asking if the word
Allah was being used in a confusing way.
>> Okay. Show me what you're you're
referring to.
>> Okay. So, this is chapter 5 verse 72.
>> 75 verse 72.
>> This is chapter 5.
>> Oh, say maha verse 72.
>> Verse 72. I have it on the screen. If
you want to look at it, if you have the
Quran on you as well, you can go ahead
and use that. That's fine.
>> You have the Can Can you bring up the
Arabic, please?
>> Sure.
>> Thank you.
>> There we go. So, I got both the Arabic
and the English up for you. It says,
"They have certainly disbelieved who say
Allah is the Messiah, son of Mary."
Would that bring confusion about the
word Allah?
>> No.
>> Oh, why not? They're using it for Jesus.
>> Because it says they have certainly
disbelieved. It's stating is stating
that that see the the initial they have
certainly disbelieved. Who say? So, he's
removing the confusion by that
statement.
>> Oh, but it was at once confused. The
word Allah was confused for Jesus.
>> Yeah, the Christians confused it. The
Christians was the Christians who the
Paul was the one who confused the word.
>> No worries. No worries. You can you
could accuse Paul, accuse whoever you
want. So we see that the word Allah was
used in confusion, but yet Allah still
kept the word
>> by the Muslims or by Paul.
>> By the Muslims.
>> No.
>> So Allah still kept the word Allah even
though it was being used in confusion.
>> Yeah. Just like Okay. Just like they
say, I give you an example. This I give
an example. Your name is Avery, right?
>> Yeah, it is. And let's say somebody
misapplies my name Avery to something
else that is not me.
>> No. No. Yeah. What if somebody called
Huh?
>> Yeah, that would be wrong.
>> If someone called me Avery, but my name
is Rashid, I would have to correct them.
If you if someone believed my name was
Avery because you had people uh 20 40
people said my name was Avery
>> who may have lied to them, I would have
to correct them and use your name Avery.
Right. So you wouldn't you wouldn't get
rid of my name. You would just
>> Right. I would correct it. I would
correct it.
>> Really quick, Rashid, so you can hear me
out.
>> So you wouldn't get rid of my name. You
would give the correct of application to
my name. Correct.
>> Yes. And that's what that's what's being
done in that verse.
>> All right. So show me now. Show me where
cuz you said Allah. They were the
Christians confused and distorted
father. The word father. So Allah is an
father but they just the word father is
not in that verse. The word father is
not
>> I didn't say that. I need you to listen
Rasheed. Please please please listen.
>> I didn't say that father is in that word
in that verse. I'm I showed you that
because of your argument for why the
Quran does not use the term father. You
said that it doesn't use the term father
because the term father was used in
confusion. It was distorted.
>> So we're talking about a lot. I thought
we're talking about
>> the word father. The word father.
Remember in the beginning
>> we're talking about Allah. We're talking
about the word father now because we
were we were talking about Allah.
>> Hey, brother. If you if you can't if you
can't keep up, man, I'm going just
>> I'm just asking a question, man. Because
I'm just trying to make sure I'm with
you. That's all because we were just
talking about Allah.
>> Said I said this and you're not
listening. You're not listening. Listen,
please. I just said
>> that the reason why we're here is
because you said when we were talking
about the term father, you said the
Quran does not use the term father
because Christians confused it.
>> So therefore Allah in his wisdom
eliminated the term. Right.
>> Correct.
>> Okay. So I asked you I said okay let's
be consistent. The term Allah, the
Christians also used it in confusion by
applying it to Jesus. They used they c
they said the Messiah is Allah. But you
said, "No, Allah doesn't eliminate the
term Allah. He just corrects them and
says no, that's wrong. Here's the real
Allah, right? He doesn't eliminate the
term." So
>> no, why would he eliminate his name?
>> Why would he eliminate father if he
truly is the father?
>> His name is not father. His name is
Allah. Allah has the most beautiful of
names, doesn't he?
>> It's not father.
>> Very good. It ain't
>> father's not one of his names. Father is
not one of his names.
>> I got you. So once so when Jesus says
that he submits to his father, he ain't
talking about Allah, is he?
>> Yes. He's talking about the creator of
the heavens and the earth.
>> Allah's father is not one of Allah's
names. That's not him.
>> Yeah. That was that was one of the names
that they said in in in the time of
Jesus. But we're talking we're talking
about the time of Jesus or we're talking
about the time of Muhammad.
>> Oh, I I understand. So you're saying
>> yeah because the confusion was there. It
was no confusion there. I got you
>> when Jesus used the term. It wasn't any
confusion. The confusion came after.
>> Got you. So you're saying that Allah
changes. Is that right?
>> No. People change the meaning.
>> So let me get this straight.
>> Allah stays the same. I can't change.
>> Once upon a time, one of Allah's names
in Jesus's time was father. Right.
>> If he used that term. Yeah. I would say
yes. I agree.
>> So his name used to be father.
>> Got you. His name used to be father.
Then Muhammad comes along because after
some confusion with the Christians,
Muhammad comes along and now after
Muhammad, Allah's name is no longer
father. Is that right?
>> Yeah. But who revealed the Quran to
Muhammad?
>> Allah.
>> Allah. So he didn't ch but no through
his wisdom he did not choose to use
father because of the
>> kiss of the
>> so Allah's Allah changed his name
>> from being father to now it's he it's no
longer father so Allah changed right
>> yeah he he has he has yes he could do
that he's he's Allah
>> so you're like he changed many things in
the past have he not
>> so Allah
>> so you would say that the new covenant
is different different from the old cup.
So he changed the old cup. He did.
>> Appreciate you for coming, dog.